well today you may notice more people
are wearing blue it is to bring
awareness to the issue of human
trafficking when we're sadly very
familiar with here in southern nevada
bianca holman is live this morning with
a look at some efforts to really make
sure everyone stays safe on the streets
across the valley bianca
good morning so from dark sleepy towns
and
country roads to big city lights and
busy streets like here in las vegas
human trafficking it can happen anywhere
the department of state estimates as
many as 24.9 million adults and children
are trapped in some form of human
trafficking around the world including
here in the u.s so january is a month to
raise awareness around the issue and
prevention work here in the valley the
u.s national human trafficking hotline
saw a nearly 20 percent increase from
2018 to 2019 and covet hasn't stopped
that increase more teens are spending
more time
unsupervised on devices which can lead
to an easy way for predators to target
victims but advocates want to remind
people that predators aren't always a
stranger it could be an associate or
even a family member groups like refuge
for women and the cupcake girls they
provide resources in the valley for
those that are being trafficked here and
the cupcake girl says they have seen a
200 clients a year now and that's a
major increase in starting back in 2011.
when there's
lack of strong communities for the folks
that we're working with they end up very
vulnerable to trafficking situations and
so what we really work to do is provide
opportunity to build strong community we
do that through support groups community
events um and and many other things
where
we try and we try and bridge the gap
between isolation to
healthy relationship
now the cupcake girls are having a
fundraiser this month called act local
and it's a chance for local shops and
restaurants to raise awareness and funds
for the non-profit to help survivors and
so here are a few businesses
participating you can see them on your
screen now places like classic jewel for
the love frankie's uptown just cupcakes
lv and rick rix rolling a barbecue each
of those doing something today to help
raise some money all of them having
their own deal whether it's a cocktail
or a special menu item so you can
definitely check that out and help raise
money so that we can combat this issue
here in las vegas reporting live bianca
holman live local now